the hardest thing is when you're making
this content is not getting traction
people want to give up like when you
make a video and it gets two views it
feels shitty but the reality is
everybody started at two views Mr Beast
got two views that's how it starts and
so like I did videos in this store when
YouTube first came out in 2006 for
months and months and months and got no
views 80 60 40. but if you love the
videos you're making and you're talking
about [__] that you're interested in
then you're just loving the making of
the video and then the results will come
a year or two later so you do it because
you want to make it the video is not
because you want the subscribers or the
fame